Why Do We Knock On Wood?
You’ve probably said this phrase and performed
this action countless times, without the slightest
clue as to the meaning behind it.
So why do we feel compelled to “knock on
wood” as an insurance policy against bad
luck?
Unfortunately, nobody knows for sure and while
you’ll often read detailed accounts of how
the saying comes from centuries old practices
by various peoples (depending on the origin
theory you’re reading), oddly enough the
expression itself only popped up a little
over a hundred years ago, first documented
in 1905, with the British equivalent “touch
wood,” popping up in 1899.
As for the various theories of how the expression
came to be, these include that most Pagan
cultures in the ancient world – from Ireland
to India – believed that trees were inhabited
by nature spirits, and often incorporated
them into their rituals and worship.
Thus, the theory goes that it was thought
that one could simply knock on the bark of
a tree to invoke the aid of the benevolent
nature spirit residing within.
The Irish also supposedly believed this was
how you thanked the little people, or leprechauns,
for any good luck you’ve been experiencing.
So over time, knocking on the tree may have
become a way of showing gratitude for a run
of particularly good luck, and the acknowledgement
that the nature spirits deserve thanks for
blessings received, in case they got miffed
and caused your luck to change from good to
bad.
Mortals provoking the ire of the gods is never
a good idea, so respect is crucial to avoiding
serious backlash – and bad luck.
Yet another theory gives credit to Christians,
who elevated twisting Pagan tradition for
their own purposes to an art form.
In this theory, the wood in question is the
cross that Christ was crucified on.
Knocking on the wood, more or less then invokes
Christ’s protection.
There’s also a Jewish version of “knock
on wood” origin that contends the practice
originated in the 1490s during the Spanish
Inquisition under the infamous Torquemada.
Jews were running for their lives at the time,
and as synagogues and temples were built from
wood, coded knocks were devised so Jews could
gain entry.
This resulted in many lives being saved, so
“knocking on wood” became synonymous with
good luck according to this origin theory.
All that said, again, despite the supposedly
ancient origin of knocking on wood for luck,
the earliest documented references of the
expression “knock on wood” and “touch
wood” date back only a little over a century
ago.
If we go a little further back, to the early
1800s we find a series of children’s chasing
games, including “Tiggy-touch-wood,” where
one of the rules state that you cannot be
tagged if you “touch wood.”
This was an extremely popular game at the
time, and could very well be how the British
equivalent of”knock on wood,” “touch
wood,” came about; that may have in turn
given rise to “knock on wood” across the
pond.
Or perhaps not, but at least this particular
“touch wood” origin theory seems plausible
enough with a slightly more direct connection
to the phrase over any ancient spiritual origin
theories.
Given the two expressions mean pretty much
the same thing and first popped up around
the same time, there’s bound to be tangible
connection.
Unfortunately, just what that connection is
and how, for certain, these expressions came
to be has been lost to history.